is Donald Trump the cleanest guy in
politics maybe or is the doj just
incompetent and corrupt certainly the
latter there there's a headline just
comes out of the doj Watchdog which says
that the doj Watchdog has concluded
try not if you're driving please pull
over
I don't want you to laugh yourself into
a car accident they've concluded that
Jeffrey Epstein killed himself
say that again they the doj watchdog
says that Jeffrey Epstein the most
famous intelligence connected sex
trafficking with minors buddy of
billionaires and heads of state and
royalty and a lot of powerful people he
just he just killed himself oopsie Daisy
I don't really I don't buy that
and you don't buy that and nobody buys
that
to the credit of the Associated Press
they're at least filling in a little
more color there and pointing out that
that the Watchdog did find some
misconduct by federal jail guards that
allow Jeffrey Epstein to commit suicide
but there's a lot of coincidences
the jail guard doesn't take his security
walk the other jail guard doesn't make a
security Walk The One camera goes out
what about the other what about a second
camera a second camera it actually that
accidentally malfunctions too how did he
oh he just accidentally had exactly the
right amount of time to kill himself I
don't think so
now
what does it mean that nobody believes
that Jeffrey Epstein killed himself it
means that our government is more
corrupt or at least more transparently
corrupt than it has been in our
lifetimes and when our government is
transparently corrupt people start to
look for Alternatives who seem like they
are outside of the political
establishment which explains
pretty amazing poll that just came out
from morning consult which is
about the 2024 GOP Primary and you know
who's number one and you know who's
number two you might be surprised to
know that Mike Pence is number three but
just behind Mike Pence at number four
the vague ramaswamy
the vague ramaswamy is an entrepreneur
he's 37 years old very few people had
heard of him until quite recently the
vague it is a tech guy he it was written
a couple of books
that's it
and Vivek right now is polling at six
percent which is twice
the next candidate on the list he's
polling twice Nikki Haley U.N Ambassador
and former governor of South Carolina
he's pulling twice Tim Scott a sitting
U.S senator
he's bowling three times Chris Christie
a two-term governor who is leading the
chrysosons but not nearly as much as the
Ramos ramaswamasans I don't know uh he's
six times ASA Hutchinson I can't believe
he's even on the poll burgum is at zero
Suarez is it zero herd is it zero
someone else that's a candidate someone
else capital S capital E is pulling at
one percent so tied with Hutchinson
that's a very impressive number
so congratulations to Vivek in the Roman
Swami campaign that's that's really
impressive and it tells you something
about the time we're living in which is
that if you are viewed to be part of the
political establishment that is a
liability for you one other weird little
bit of color on this poll is a lot of
people are asking how is Mike Pence at
seven percent the way that Mike Pence is
at seven percent is one the man was the
vice president of the United States not
all that long ago the man was a popular
governor of Indiana the man was a
popular Congressman so he's got a lot of
support and he also leans into more of
the establishment side of the
conservative movement the Republican
party and there are still a lot of
people there it's very easy to get lost
with a tide of rising populism in this
idea that the establishment's totally
done and vanquished it's not and you saw
this same kind of thing happening in
1980 which is why the 1980 presidential
ticket for the right was Ronald Reagan
who was the Conservative candidate and
George H.W bush who was the more
establishment
Country Club kind of candidate
and Mike Pence who is more conservative
than George Bush is is actively running
in that More Country Club establishment
Lane he's talking about how we need to
lay off companies how not like not lay
them off like layoff workers meaning
layoff like stop attacking companies
return to just the same old sort of
mantras and mottos of the Reagan Era so
he's running in that lane and I suspect
what Pence is thinking is well okay
maybe this doesn't describe the majority
of the base right now but they're
Reagan had to pick bush in 1980 tonight
the party maybe somebody will pick me to
be vice president or maybe somehow I'll
be the nominee as well right now go to
expressvpn.com Michael Knowles show let
me ask you something when you use the
restroom you always close the door
behind you right you don't want random
passers-by looking in on you so why
would you let people look in on you when
you go online
using the internet without expressvpn is
like going to the restroom and not
closing the door okay I love expressvpn
I'm a total Luddite so I barely know how
to use any technology but it's so easy
to use even I can use it you just
download it one click of a button on
your cell phone on your laptop on your
on your iPad on whatever you want I can
say with full confidence expressvpn is
the best VPN on the market here's why
number one expressvpn doesn't log your
online activity they even developed a
trusted server technology that makes it
impossible for their servers to store
any data at all number two speed
expressvpn does not slow down your user
experience you can stream HD videos with
zero buffering number three expressvpn
is incredibly easy to use
it's that one button you're done you're
good to go if you're like me you believe
your online activity is your business
use our link expressvpn.com Michael
Knowles show today get three months free
in a one-year package
expresvpn.com Michael Knowles show
expressvpn.com Michael Knowles show
Marco Rubio I like Marco Rubio
I think his heart basically is in the
right place or at least his his
political mind is basically roughly in
the right place but he's gone
he's gone off the deep end Mr Rubio
because Marco Rubio is entertaining all
this UFO stuff
and many of them incredible well I don't
find them either not credible or
credible because we have no basis but we
understand some of these claims are
things that are Beyond sort of the realm
of what any of us has ever dealt with
what I think we owe them is just a
mature you know understand listening and
trying to put these all these pieces
together and just sort of intake the
information without any prejudgment or
jumping to any conclusions in One
Direction or another I will say I find
most of these people at some point or
maybe even currently have held very high
clearances and high positions within our
government so you start out you do ask
yourself like what incentive would so
many people with that kind of um
qualification these are serious people
have to come forward and make something
up
what what kind of incentive would they
have
uh Senator Rubio come on
he's saying look I'm not rushing to
judgment I'm not saying I believe them I
don't believe in that he's saying why
would they make it up it's he's saying
the same thing Walsh says
let me explain to you
what the aliens are and I was reminded
of this verse by my friend Taylor
Marshall and a good take on it
right right podcaster Catholic guy
lesions
chapter 2 verse 2. herein in time past
you walked according to the course of
this world according to the prince of
the power of this air
of the spirit that now worketh on the
children of unbelief
UFOs are just little things that we see
in the sky that defy physical
explanation
I don't want to just be like the guy in
the History Channel
it's demons guys it's just it's it's
just demons that's what it is
and the people Walsh aside and this is
what bugs me about Rubio embracing this
too Walsh solid Catholic guy but he
falls into this thing
the UFO stuff the alien stuff which is
just demonology for Liberal atheists
that's all it is because the people have
known for all of human history that
spiritual realities exist and that there
are things that are physical and there
are things there are things that are
physical and don't have a rational Soul
like a rock
then there are things that are physical
and do have a rational Soul like human
beings
there are things that are not physical
they're metaphysical like ideas and Love
and Hope and Mathematics and
Angels and Demons
that there are intelligences that do not
have physical form if you believe in God
let's not even get into the specifics on
your religious views if you believe that
God exists and don't forget the
existence of God can be known with
certainty by the natural light of human
reason from the created world
if you believe and you can there are
many very good Arguments for God's
existence
and God's existence is necessary and we
can know that it's true just from the
world around us using our own reason
then you know that God
is metaphysical
God takes on a body in the Incarnation
in the second person of the Trinity
Jesus Christ
but God the Father God the Holy Spirit
metaphysical
it doesn't it's not not just like an old
guy with a beard in the sky as the
liberal atheists try to pretend they try
to pretend that we believe that so if
you acknowledge that there are there is
at least one intelligence one
intelligent being that doesn't have a
body then you know Angels and Demons
flow from that and then of course if you
follow
your
reason to say okay I know that God
exists well what can I know about God
and then you turn to revelation
you see Angels everywhere and every
every group of people for all of human
history until like just stupid modern
liberal atheists believed that Angels
and Demons exist
by the way the stupid liberal modern
atheists they believe that too
they believe it when they get in the
foxholes they believe it when they get
into a bad spot they believe it even
when they talk about their fallen
comrades let's say oh so and so had
demons oh yeah a guy who died of a drug
overdose yeah he boy he sure had his
demons everybody talks about it
but now we've got to pretend that
everything's physical
to say oh pretty soon they're going to
say odd poor Johnny died there drunk in
the gutter doing a bunch of drugs and
all that well he had his aliens
oh that boy he was tormented by Martians
that's my but they're just there they
are demons boy what a great clip that
was make sure you ring that Bell
subscribe to the Michael Knowles YouTube
channel we'll see you next time